the clock is ticking until the first
Bell Rings today CCSD welcomed its new
teachers at a teacher kickoff event at
the Rio all to help prepare for the new
school year Mary Jane bellies are
joining us live with how the district is
hoping to fill teacher positions Mary
Jane a critical need
Educators from the Clark County School
District say they have worked tirelessly
to hire teachers not just locally but
Nationwide and internationally too
hopefully this is an amazing year like
um every teacher here is the Clark
County School District has hired over
800 new teachers and over 100 new school
bus drivers for the
2022-2023 school year new teacher
salaries have now increased to over 50
thousand dollars bus driver and
substitute wages have increased as well
as the president of ccea I hear from
Educators on a regular basis and we
definitely need to continue to address
the teacher shortage through our salary
increases and our benefit increases and
things like that Educators deserve to be
paid like professionals and that's been
a struggle here in Nevada new teachers
moving here from another state are
eligible for a four thousand dollar
bonus Carol tokes chief of HR at the
school district says the salary
increases should help retain teachers
we're still trying to fill around 1300
vacancies but we're really excited about
that because partly what that shows is
that our principals are trying to stick
to low-class sizes so we are doing
everything we can every day to help
support them by tiring and digging for
candidates everywhere we look the search
to fill vacancies includes branching out
to teachers internationally CCSD has
hired over 99 teachers overseas with J-1
visas and are expecting 30 more
International teachers to arrive before
the start of the school year for us it's
uh it's a new experience though we
partly we don't know what to expect but
we're excited to be here at it's a great
thing to be here because we are hoping
for new learnings and Advance
advancements for our career
the Clark County School District plans
to continually recruit teachers and
anticipates fill rates will improve
throughout the school year reporting
from the Rio Mary Jane valleza live
local now Mary Jane thank you and as she
just mentioned those vacancies there are
quite a few CCSD looking to fill more
than 2 000 School staff positions
thousands of open teacher positions more
than 600 support staff positions
available you can find more information
on how to apply on the CCSD website